We'll now talk about the algorithmic
problem of sorting by reversals.
Let's start from a short chromosome
consisting of just 10 blocks
and we'll number them in the order
1, 2, 3 to 10.
Now a reversal... we can think about a
reversal as something that breaks
a chromosome at two places and glues the
resulting pieces in
a new order as shown on this slide.
And as a result, the
reversal introduces two breakpoints,
disruptions in the gene order.
For example, +3 and -8 are not
supposed to be together but they are
together in the new permutation, and the
same thing applies to -4 and +9.
So let's take a look at one of the possible
rearrangement scenarios.
In this case, transforming a permutation
into an identity permutation which is
+1 +2 +8 with these five reversals.
Is it the shortest scenario?
No, because there is a shorter scenario
that transforms the same permutation into
identity with just four reversals.
And we will define reversal distance as
the minimum
number of reversals to transform one
permutation into another.
Biologists are often interested in
shortest scenarios
for transforming one genome into another
because
this shorter scenario often corresponds to
the biological
scenario or comes close to the biological
scenarios.
So we now have a transformation of one
genome into another with just four
reversals,
but maybe there is even faster
transformations
of these genomes with just three
reversals.
And the reversal distance problem is the
problem of calculating the reversal
distance
between two permutations.
Input: two permutations,
Output: the reversal distance between them.
We will also be talking about sorting by
reversal problem
which uses an input of just a
single permutation
and ask for the reversal distance between
this permutation
and the identity permutation +1, +2, ..., +n
Why identity permutations?
Because we are at liberty to label the
final permutation the way we
want and we usually label this as
+1, +2, +3, ....
Now, what would be the most natural
algorithm for sorting by reversals?
I'm not saying good algorithm, but the
most natural one?
Let's look at this mouse permutation, for
an example of this case.
+1 is already in the right position in
this permutation,
but +2 is not.
However, we can use a
reversal, shown in bold here, to bring
plus 2 at the right position.
That's what we've done right here.
We brought +2 at the right position,
but now it has a wrong sign.
Not a problem.
We will reverse the sign using a short
reversal right here.
Now, we placed both
+1 and +2at the right position,
but -3 is at the wrong position.
Not a problem, we'll find a reversal that
brings it at the right position.
Now let's take care of +4.
Once again, let's find a reversal that
brings it to the right position.
It now has wrong sign, but we will reverse it.
And we will continue doing this until we
finally, using this Greedy algorithm,
transform mouse into Philip.
And after we looked at the Greedy algorithm
for sorting by reversal, you may
notice that of course, it's not optimal.
We used 11 reversals to transform mouse
into human permutations, but we know
from the first slide in this lecture that
it can be done in just seven reversals.
So, maybe we should come up with
a better algorithm, and to do this we
will have to define the notion of
a breakpoint graph.